- Plongée imminente.
- Soupape fermée.
Descente à 5 degrés,
immersion périscopique.
En avant 2/3...
Très bien. Indiquez
le régime moteur pour 10 nœuds.
Parfait.
Officier de quart,
parez les tubes 1, 2, 3 et 4.
J'ai un visuel à l'horizon,
immersion périscopique,
relèvement 0-5-0.
Verrouillez cible numéro 1.
Parfait, lancez tubes 1 et 2.
November, Alpha 1-1-3 à tous
les bâtiments en Alpha Tango 0-4-2.
Maintenez position
avant confirmation.
Ordre du commandant,
Alpha 1-1-3.
Arrêtez les moteurs.
Mon frère a été blessé en Sicile.
Il est dans la 7e Armée de Patton.
Il a perdu un pied.
Relèvement de la cible 0-3-0,
déviation à 1 800 mètres,
angle de 5º.
Attendez.
Nous avons une solution de tir.
Votre attention.
Autorisation de fumer...
Autorisation de fumer
à bord du bateau.
Autorisation de fumer...
Que fichez-vous là ?
Secret défense.
L'accès au Lionfish est interdit.
On va voir ça !
C'est mon bateau.
- Désolé, j'ai reçu des ordres.
- De qui ?
- L'amiral Roberts.
- Ah oui ? Où est le chef d'escadre ?
- À bord du Bainbridge.
- Voyons ce qu'il en dit.
Chef de quart, qu'y a-t-il ?
Le commandant
conteste les mesures prises.
- Il est allé voir le chef d'escadre.
- Bien. Continuez.
Le commandant du Lionfish est là.
Votre attention.
Il est interdit de fumer
pendant le remplissage du réservoir.
Poussez-vous de là !
Signez ici, commandant.
Vous débarquez ici comme...
J'ai dû revenir du Pacifique pour ça ?
Nous en avons parlé
au briefing d'hier.
- N'est-ce pas ?
- Je vois !
C'est grave,
mais je peux encore patrouiller ?
Désolé, je ne peux pas...
Ils prennent mon bateau ! Bon sang !
J'ai donné ma vie, ma famille,
vous voulez aussi mon âme ?
Qu'est-ce que ça changera ?
Je saurai me faire écouter
en haut lieu.
Un seul mot de tout ça
et vous irez commander des pioches
au pénitencier de Leavenworth.
Acceptez cette fichue promotion.
Fermez-la.
Je vois : "soyez sympa,
dites amen à tout".
"Oui chef, formidable".
En regardant pourrir mon bateau,
le cul sur une chaise.
Ça changera quoi ?
Sûrement pas la marine.
Autant me mettre au placard.
Qui voulez-vous mettre au placard ?
- Repos, messieurs.
- Amiral, nous...
Amiral, je...
- Je sais que c'est très dur.
- Ça l'est.
Je vous demande seulement
une seconde chance.
Commandant !
Oubliez ce satané bateau.
Et allez profiter de votre famille.
Ma femme veut me quitter.
Vous êtes promu.
Dans une école de formation.
Vous forgerez les nouvelles recrues.
Allons, Tony.
C'est d'accord, Amiral.
Votre attention.
La permission débutera à 16h.
Je répète, la permission
débutera à 16h.
Commandant, le bateau est prêt.
- Le bateau est prêt.
- Excellent, messieurs.
- Les photos ?
- J'ai terminé.
Envoyez ça illico
aux Renseignements Navals.
Très bon travail, continuez.
- Lieutenant, éteignez tout.
- Bien.
Votre attention...
Verrouillez l'écoutille.
Balayeurs, au travail.
Nettoyez le bateau
de fond en comble.
Balayeurs, terminé.
Un capitaine doit sombrer
avec son bateau.
Tu perds ton temps
à chasser les fantômes
avec ton copain cinglé.
- Mike n'est pas cinglé.
- Ce n'est pas ton travail.
Si, c'est ce que j'enseigne.
- La Marine US...
- 70 ans de silence !
La Marine n'a jamais mené
de recherches paranormales
dans les années 40.
Ce sous-marin fantôme
que tu cherches n'existe pas.
Le ministère de la Défense et
l'état-major de la Marine se plaignent.
Crois-tu à des recherches
paranormales à cette époque ?
Tu les bombardes
de demandes
d'informations absurdes...
C'est comme ça
que j'ai obtenu ça.
Laisse tomber. Concentre-toi
sur ce que tu sais faire.
Mais...
C'est mon droit de réclamer
ces documents sur mon grand-père.
Regarde.
Il ne s'agit pas...
d'élucubrations ni d'une absurde
chasse aux fantômes.
Tes élèves se plaignent
que tu empestes l'alcool en cours.
Et que fais-tu avec une bouteille
sur ton bureau ?
Qui me l'a offerte ?
"Joyeux anniversaire", Robert.
Ne gâche pas tout pour ça.
Tu vas ruiner ta réputation
pour ces bêtises.
Ok.
C'est ça ou ton poste.
C'est bon. Eh bien écoute.
Et si je te rendais la tâche
bien plus facile
en te disant
que je démissionne.
Libre à toi de ruiner ta carrière.
Tu peux te mettre cette bouteille
de bon rhum dans le cul,
espèce de connard.
Santé ! Et bonne journée.
Vicki !
Apporte une boîte.
Je m'appelle George Cullen.
Je faisais partie
de l'équipe d'ingénieurs du Lionfish
en 1943.
J'ai commencé en salle des machines,
puis j'ai été guetteur.
Ça me plaisait d'être guetteur,
parce qu'on sortait sur la passerelle
prendre la relève du type qui était là,
qui descendait
prendre son petit-déjeuner...
PETER WILLIAMS
DÉPARTEMENT D'HISTOIRE
J'ai appelé pas mal de gens,
mais personne n'a de réponse.
Ceux qui disent qu'ils
rappelleront ne le font jamais.
J'ignore vraiment
pourquoi on nous a caché ça.
Tous ceux que j'ai appelés
ont vécu la même chose.
Où était-il toutes ces années ?
Pourquoi est-il revenu ?
Personne ne sait
ce qui s'est passé il y a 70 ans.
Ça me plaisait d'être guetteur,
parce qu'on...
Foutez le camp !
Foutez le camp.
Je vous ai dit de foutre le camp.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux ?
Est-ce que ça va ?
Incroyable cette démission !
Vous allez répondre ?
Non.
Sérieusement ?
Oui.
Oui, vous allez répondre ou...
Oui, sérieusement
je ne vais pas répondre.
Vous êtes chez Peter Williams.
Oui, je vous le passe.
C'est pour vous.
Oui.
Oui, c'est bien
le professeur Williams.
Quoi ?
Qui est-ce ?
J'ai un message pour vous.
Oui, allez vous faire foutre.
C'était qui ?
Ne réponds pas.
Et là, vous allez répondre ?
Tu as perdu la tête ?
Tu as démissionné ?
Allô ?
Pardon, je te croyais seul.
- Il n'a pas apprécié.
- Quoi ? Passe-le-moi !
Apprécié quoi ?
Écoute, si c'est une...
plaisanterie,
je vais t'arracher la tête...
Quoi ?
Comment vous savez ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Demain. Le 13 de ce mois.
Sérieux ?
Non, bien sûr.
Bien sûr.
- J'ai réussi.
- À t'attirer des ennuis ?
- J'arrive pas à y croire !
- À croire quoi ?
On a accès au Lionfish !
On a 24 heures
pour faire des recherches à bord.
Sans blague ! Vous plaisantez ?
J'ai besoin de toute mon équipe.
Et de toi.
Comptez sur moi !
T'es sérieux ?
Tu viens aussi.
On va enfin savoir
pour mon grand-père.
- Tu ne veux pas savoir ?
- Non, sans façon.
C'est la cause de notre divorce.
J'en ai rien à foutre.
Entre ta mère
complètement gâteuse
et toi obnubilé par ton grand-père,
tu crois vraiment
que j'ai envie de repartir là-dedans ?
T'es là depuis le début.
On épluchera ensemble ces archives.
J'ai besoin de toi
pour m'aider
à traiter toutes ces données.
Nous n'avons que...
24 heures.
Un jour.
Je n'ai pas le droit à l'erreur.
Stace.
Je ne peux pas y arriver
sans toi.
Merde, je dois appeler Mike !
Quoi ?
Non...
Pas Mike !
C'est pour vous.
700 livres ?
Ça ne va pas la tête ?
Hé, 700 livres !
C'est le coût de votre fantôme.
Parfois on les trouve,
mais pas toujours.
Trois jours à fouiner par ici
et vous espérez que...
Les voilà, vos 700 livres.
"Mike Paranormal" ?
Salut, Peter.
Non, ça va.
Quel bruit ?
Aucun bruit.
Quitte pas.
Non, je suis libre.
Ouais, bien sûr.
Sans problème.
Voilà ce qu'on va faire.
Je vais prendre un avion
dès demain matin.
Oui, j'ai hâte aussi.
Je dois y aller.
Putain !
C'est toujours l'enfer
pour trouver votre maison.
Ça a dû me coûter une fortune.
Allez, viens là.
- Bienvenue en Amérique.
- Ça va ?
- Tu fais du sport, dis donc !
- Toi aussi.
- Alors, on part en camping ?
- C'est ça.
Sur l'USS Lionfish !
Quand tu m'as dit ça...
On sera les premiers à monter
sur ce bateau depuis cet événement.
T'y crois, toi ?
Pas vraiment, non.
- Stace.
- Bonjour, Mike.
- Tu vas bien ?
- Oui.
- Ça fait plaisir.
- Elle est en forme.
Hier, j'étais chez moi
et ce type m'appelle
du ministère de la Défense.
Un certain Garmin.
Et pourquoi juste maintenant ?
- Garmin ?
- Oui.
Une chose m'échappe.
Pourquoi lever subitement
un si long secret défense ?
Ça me dépasse, mais je prends.
Tu vois ?
- C'est Vicki ?
- Oui.
Regarde, c'est Mike.
On aurait dû faire venir
ces types
de l'émission sur le paranormal.
- Inutile puisque tu es là.
- Exact.
"Mike et le Paranormal",
ça sonne bien.
- Sérieusement ?
- Ce nom me plaît.
Tous en voiture.
Allez !
Stace !
- On y va !
- Allez, les filles !
Voilà voilà.
Où est Stace ? Dépêche-toi, chérie.
Et voilà, les enfants. Soyez sages.
Garmin.
Faites-les entrer.
Allez-y. Ouvrez le portail.
Ils sont là.
- Excellent. Qui ?
- Williams et 3 autres.
Et tenez-vous bien,
il y a son ex-femme.
Vous avez compris
les ordres et les consignes ?
- Compris.
- Parfait.
Regardez-moi ça !
Un vrai bateau de guerre !
Pr Williams,
pour des recherches...
- Nous vous attendions.
- Joli navire.
On dit "bateau" pour un sous-marin.
Et pourquoi cela ?
"Navire" ne s'applique pas
aux sous-marins,
car autrefois,
ils devaient être remorqués.
Tu savais pas ça ?
Il n'y a que deux types
de bateaux au monde :
les sous-marins et les cibles.
Vous vouliez l'accès ?
Le voici.
Il est plutôt sympa.
Allons chercher les sacs.
C'est bon ?
Mike Morris et son équipe
paranormale vont embarquer
sur l'USS Lionfish.
Tu peux le faire taire ?
Attendez une minute.
Ce bateau est sûrement hanté.
Bourré de trucs paranormaux.
Ok.
Allez, c'est parti.
Bon sang !
Un peu de nerf, professeur.
Ok.
Passe-moi mon sac, Mikey.
Merci.
Je vais descendre.
J'y vais.
Je suis en bas.
Nom de Dieu, Garmin !
Bon, on prend les sacs.
À toi, grand-père.
Putain !
C'était quoi ?
Mon Dieu...
À quand remonte sa mort ?
Il m'a foutu une de ces trouilles...
- Votre grand-père.
- Comment saviez-vous...
Le Cdt Sterling a disparu
le jour où il devait embarquer.
Ce n'était qu'une supposition,
jusqu'à présent.
J'allais te demander si ça allait,
mais je vois que oui.
Je bois par envie, non par besoin.
Bien, tu n'as pas
besoin de moi non plus.
Écoute. Je suis désolé d'avoir bu.
Mais je suis tellement en colère
et bouleversé.
Toutes ces années
de recherches et de...
d'investigation sur le sort
de mon grand-père...
Et il s'est tué.
Tout ça pour un suicide.
C'est vraiment...
du gâchis.
Mike, tu peux sortir ma tablette ?
J'ai pas confiance en ce type.
Il cache quelque chose.
- Qui, Mike ?
- Quoi ?
Non, imbécile.
En qui, alors ?
Je me contrefous
de ce que fait M. Garmin.
Tant qu'il n'interfère pas
dans mes recherches,
M. Garmin peut faire
ce qui lui chante.
Doit-on appeler quelqu'un
pour ton grand-père ?
Comme du personnel médical...
Il n'ira pas bien loin.
C'est pas le moment.
- Qu'est-ce qu'il a ?
- Ton humour doit l'irriter.
Oui, c'est moi.
L'équipe de Williams s'installe.
Mais écoutez ça.
Le commandant Sterling
est toujours à bord.
Ça ressemble à un suicide.
Il a laissé une lettre.
Non, c'est moi qui l'ai.
Oui.
Non, ce n'est pas un problème.
Tout se passe comme prévu.
Je dois vous laisser.
De la visite.
Ça devrait vous intéresser.
Vendredi 13. Génial.
La marine, blablabla.
Le Lionfish servira de navire
d'entraînement dans l'Atlantique,
sera rééquipé...
- Le capitaine a été affecté la veille.
- Quoi ?
Il n'était pas en cale sèche ?
Si.
Mais ces documents...
Même signature, même date,
mais contenus différents.
Fais voir.
Les premiers pas
vers la vérité concernant
le Lionfish.
- Sérieux ?
Sur ce bateau, on a un cadavre
et une histoire de fou.
Si tu le dis.
Prenons une photo d'équipe.
Super idée !
Je la mettrai sur mon site :
"Mike Morris, expert
en investigations paranormales."
Elle n'ira pas sur ton site.
On la prend ?
D'accord.
Faisons-la et finissons-en.
Souriez !
Vous voulez bien...
C'est bon ?
Prêts ? Tout le monde dit :
- "Lionfish".
- Feu !
Ça s'ouvre pas.
- Mikey.
- Attendez...
- Ça va ?
- J'ai vu un truc.
C'était sûrement
un simple courant d'air.
- Et voilà !
- Lève-toi.
Regarde.
Tu vois ? C'est ouvert.
Non, c'était sûrement
un truc paranormal.
Un courant d'air ne fait pas
claquer une porte de 200 kg.
Et j'ai vu un truc.
Mike ! Hé, revenez !
La porte s'est ouverte,
l'incident est clos.
Pousse le levier. Plus fort.
Arrêtez, il faut se concentrer.
Arrête de le provoquer.
Mike !
Génial.
Vraiment génial.
Laisse-moi essayer.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- Ce truc est coincé !
- Mike !
Ça s'ouvre pas !
Calme-toi, descends.
- C'est rien, elle va s'ouvrir aussi.
- Qu'y a-t-il ?
Il suffit de forcer.
- C'est serré.
- Je le sens pas.
Ok, ça s'ouvre pas.
- Super.
- C'est rien.
- Il faut sortir d'ici.
- Relax !
- Cherchons une 2e sortie.
- Impossible.
C'est vraiment pas grave.
T'en fais pas !
Il est un peu claustrophobe.
Il est un peu claustrophobe ?
Génial !
Mikey !
Mike.
Mon vieux ?
Cette écoutille
est cadenassée de l'extérieur.
Tu t'en souviens ? Allez, descends.
Même en tapant sur les parois,
personne ne t'entendra.
- C'est pas si grave.
- Pas si grave ?
Parle pour toi.
Moi, j'aime pas être enfermé
dans de petits espaces,
surtout s'ils sont submersibles.
Je dois attirer l'attention.
C'est inutile.
- Quoi ?
- C'est inutile.
Redescends.
- Pourquoi ?
- Le site est désert ce soir.
Jusqu'à demain matin.
Vicki, regarde ton portable.
Il va falloir être patient, Ok ?
Vous pouvez rester là,
mais ça risque d'être long.
Vous entendez là ?
D'où ça vient, Peter ?
Ça vient de l'arrière.
Ça vient de là.
Ici.
Merde.
Des fantômes, j'en étais sûr.
- Vraiment ?
- Ici le commandant November...
Super, on est sur un bateau hanté.
Ouais, super Pete.
On est sur un rafiot de 70 ans
qui se coule lui-même.
- Tout a une explication rationnelle.
- Bien sûr.
November, Alpha 1-1-3
à tous les bateaux...
Je te l'avais dit, Pete.
Mike, rends-moi service.
Descends dans la salle des machines
pour voir ce qui se passe.
Tu peux faire ça ?
D'accord.
Vick, garde un œil sur Mike.
- Stacey, avec moi.
- On a déjà essayé,
sans grand succès.
J'arrive.
Pourquoi tant d'assurance ?
- Vous allez nous aider ou...
- Non.
Cool. Espèce d'enfoiré.
Je comprends pas.
Non. Peut-être que Mike
avait raison cette fois.
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Ça bouge tout seul.
Tu vois ça ?
T'as vu ça ?
J'y crois pas.
Ça s'éteint pas.
Ici le commandant
November, Alpha 1-1-3.
Commencez la manœuvre
en zigzag Alpha à 3 heures.
Je répète...
- Hé.
- Mikey ?
T'as touché aux commandes ?
Non, ça s'allume
tout seul dans ce navire.
Bateau.
- On l'a assez énervé.
- Attends...
Comment ça ?
Un tas de ferraille dans l'eau
n'a rien de vivant.
Ça va pas !
D'accord. Alors explique-moi ça.
Essaie de l'éteindre.
Jolie tentative.
C'est pareil partout.
- Vous avez vu ça ?
- Quoi ?
Ça !
- Je vois rien.
- Rien du tout.
Super. Et maintenant ?
Ok. Là, je commence à flipper.
Vous avez senti ça ?
On dirait qu'on va plonger.
- Je repars aux machines.
- Bonne idée.
- La vache !
- J'entends rien.
Quel bruit d'enfer.
Trouve une arrivée de carburant
ou un coupe-circuit
pour stopper ces moteurs.
Je vais à l'arrière.
C'est parti.
Mike !
Vick, va aider Mikey.
Viens, Stace.
Je vais essayer de tout éteindre
du poste central.
Viens, Stace !
Vick !
Essaie des boutons.
Je rêve ! Vous allez rester planté là
sans rien nous expliquer ?
Vous nous cachez
quelque chose, Garmin. Parlez !
Me poussez pas, bordel !
- À quel jeu vous jouez ?
- Du calme, professeur.
- Pourquoi nous avoir invités ?
- J'ai besoin d'aide.
Le moteur est énorme.
Comment on l'arrête ?
Hé !
- J'ai besoin d'aide !
- Hé !
- Regarde.
- Pousse-toi de là.
Merde !
Vous entendez ?
Je vais le réparer moi-même.
C'est pas vrai !
Stace, ça s'ouvre pas.
Nous ne sommes pas seuls ici.
Ok.
Voyons ce qui se passe.
On part en mer.
On verra bien ce qui arrivera.
On est coincés.
Regarde.
Merde.
- Ça ne donne rien.
- Mince !
Je vais vérifier les tracés.
- La Nouvelle-Angleterre, on dirait.
- Ça ne colle pas.
Comment ça ?
Merde !
Ce n'est pas le profil de la côte.
Elle a raison.
Ça sert à rien du tout...
J'ai raté quoi ?
Exact, l'écho n'est pas bon.
Où sont les ponts ?
La centrale ? Où...
- Où on est, Peter ?
- J'en sais rien !
- J'en ai ras-le-bol !
- C'est insensé.
- Où on est ?
- Non...
La question est "Quand ?"
En fait,
je pense qu'on est le 13 août 1943.
On s'arrête ?
Oui, on s'arrête !
Je vais sortir de là !
Mike !
Ne remonte pas.
Ouvre l'écoutille.
Ouvre-la de ton côté.
C'est verrouillé !
Ouvre cette écoutille !
- Viens m'aider.
- Peter...
- Quoi ?
- Regarde.
- Ouvre !
- C'est quoi ça ?
- Les ballasts s'ouvrent.
- On va plonger.
Mike, ouvre l'écoutille !
Pete !
Garmin, vous pouvez m'aider ?
- Non, désolé.
- Pete !
- Sans déconner ? Venez m'aider !
- Peter...
- Regarde.
- Quoi ?
Est-ce que...
- Les ballasts se remplissent.
- Pete !
Tenez-vous bien.
Pete !
La fermeture des écoutilles
doit faire partie du protocole
de plongée. Du moins...
je l'espère.
- 10 mètres.
- Continue.
12 mètres.
17 mètres.
18 mètres.
J'apprends vraiment
à maudire les sous-marins.
Mon Dieu !
Rien de cassé ?
Où il va, lui ?
L'écoutille...
s'est ouverte d'un coup.
Et une fois ouverte,
ce foutu truc a changé d'avis.
Comment c'est possible ?
C'est qu'un fichu bateau.
Bon, vous allez nous dire
ce qui se passe.
- Des réponses !
- Je ne peux rien dire.
Qu'est-ce que vous foutez ici alors ?
Dites-nous.
Je ne suis pas autorisé...
- Pas autorisé ?
- Dites-nous !
On va vous autoriser, nous.
- Parlez !
- Je n'ai pas le droit d'en parler.
- Je m'en fiche.
- On a failli y rester !
Maîtrisez votre femme.
- Je ne suis pas sa femme !
- Parlez !
- Du calme.
- Laissez ma femme.
Professeur...
- Arrêtez, professeur.
- Peter !
Du calme.
Vous ignorez beaucoup de choses.
Arrêtez !
Veuillez vous calmer.
Que faites-vous, madame ?
- Donnez-moi cette arme.
- Arrêtez !
Ce bateau n'est pas
conçu pour résister aux balles.
Je ne peux vous expliquer...
Qu'as-tu fait ? Je le tenais !
Pardon ? Il allait t'étrangler.
- Il ne parlera plus. Tu l'as tué !
- Et s'il t'avait tué...
Et t'es dingue de tirer
dans un sous-marin !
Tu voulais que je fasse quoi ?
T'es dingue ! On a divorcé pour ça.
- En partie.
- Bon sang !
- Pourquoi t'as fait ça ?
- Je t'ai sauvé la vie.
- Peter, je t'ai sauvé la vie.
- Je le tenais.
- Du calme.
- Putain !
Tu me reproches
de t'avoir sauvé la vie ?
Stace !
Vous ne croyez pas qu'on a
assez de problèmes comme ça ?
Tu peux fouiller le sac de Garmin ?
Avec plaisir.
Il faut l'attacher.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ici ?
Explique-moi.
On essaie de savoir ce qui se passe.
Il y a sûrement quelque chose.
C'est quoi ?
C'est un taré.
Bingo.
Ouais.
J'ai trouvé ça.
- Matos audio et vidéo...
- Des menottes.
Un problème de réglé sur cent,
pas vrai ?
Et ce regard ? C'est ma faute ?
Tu nous as amenés ici.
On est là pour ça.
Oui, je vous ai collé
un flingue sur la tempe.
On va régler ça.
- C'est de ma faute.
- D'accord.
Vous allez me détacher ?
Pourquoi ?
- Pourquoi quoi ?
- Pourquoi tout ça ?
- Expliquez-moi pourquoi.
- C'est une longue histoire.
- Revenez en arrière.
- La main !
- Baissez-la.
- Refaites-moi voir cette photo.
Laquelle ? Celle-ci ?
Pourquoi ?
Enfoiré.
Vous ne savez pas tout ?
Allez-vous me détacher ?
- Vous allez m'expliquer ?
- Non.
Alors allez vous faire foutre.
Ne bougez pas, vous êtes puni.
Pourquoi ils m'ont rien dit ?
Pourquoi t'être réfugié dans...
ta cabine pour te flinguer ?
Comme ça ?
Tu sais quoi ?
Je t'ai trouvé.
Oh, putain.
Merde.
J'aurais dû écouter mon ex-femme.
Elle avait raison.
- C'est vrai ?
- Putain !
Stacey...
Tu le reconnais enfin.
Où est...
Oui, grand-père n'est pas là.
On est en 1943, tu sais.
Il doit être par là.
On a besoin de toi.
Un dernier verre à la santé de 1943.
Je me suis toujours demandé
si tu avais raison.
On devrait être bientôt fixés.
- C'est ce que je crois ?
- Quoi ?
Au central.
Vicki, reste au sonar.
- Par ici.
- Et moi ?
- Mets-toi au relais.
- Ok.
Stace, suis-moi.
Allez !
Voilà.
Voyons ce qui se passe.
Il y a un convoi.
Un sous-marin allemand !
Torpille en approche !
On nous torpille !
Après, ils chasseront le convoi.
On doit agir.
Il y a des milliers de soldats.
Laissez-moi vous aider.
- La ferme, Garmin.
- Je suis entraîné...
Mikey, va voir ce que fait Garmin.
J'y vais.
Ces chiffres,
note-les à mon signal.
Attends, j'ai rien pour écrire.
- J'ai un stylo. Du papier ?
- Y'en avait pas...
- Trouve un truc.
- Sur ma main.
Prête ?
- Maintenant !
- 0 degré.
Attends.
Attends...
Plus près... Attends.
- Maintenant.
- 2 400 m.
- Temps ?
- 20 secondes.
2 400 mètres...
- Hé !
- Fais voir. J'arrive pas à lire !
Quoi ? J'ai les mains moites.
- Hé !
- Pas maintenant, Vicki.
En approche à 12 nœuds.
- On doit tirer...
- Peter...
- Quoi ?
- Regarde !
Le bateau est en train de nous aider.
"En attente", ça veut dire...
Merde ! Les tubes sont vides.
Il faut charger une torpille.
Charger une torpille ?
Écoute-moi. Reste ici
et préviens-moi quand le bateau
aura une solution de tir.
Je vais tenter
de charger une torpille.
Fait chier !
Très bien, d'accord.
Ok, d'accord.
Allez, Mike !
Dépêche-toi !
On doit charger une torpille
dans un de ces tubes, Ok ?
Tu veux l'introduire là-dedans ?
Regarde ces milliers de commandes.
Il suffit de charger
une torpille dans un tube.
Le bateau fera le reste.
Stacey, trouve-moi
la notice du lance-torpille.
Ok.
Je m'en occupe.
Peter...
- Torpille en approche !
- Je m'y connais.
C'est pas vrai !
Bon, Ok.
On a besoin de son aide.
Bon, pousse-toi.
Il faut la charger.
- Vous allez coopérer ?
- Ça peut pas attendre ?
- Magnez-vous.
- Bon sang !
Plus vite !
Qu'est-ce que vous foutez ?
Dépêchez-vous !
Entrez là-dedans.
Regardez. Tirez cette poignée
et montez ce levier, d'accord ?
Puis tournez ce bouton-là. Ok ?
Peter, aidez-moi
à ouvrir ces trappes.
Ouvrez la vanne d'évacuation
avant de tourner cette manivelle...
Bon, c'est pas grave.
On se dépêche,
il faut charger cette torpille.
Accrochez ça là.
Il faut déplacer ces cordes.
- Ouvrez ces trappes.
- Ça vient.
- Tu l'as ? Pousse vers moi.
- Allez !
Plus vite. Laissez-moi passer.
2, 3, hissez !
- Une autre torpille !
- 2, 3, tirez !
Vas-y, Mikey !
Allez !
Continuez.
- Allez !
- Encore un peu.
- On y est presque.
- T'arrête pas !
- Poussez-vous.
- Allez !
- Non, prenez cette poulie.
- Décrochez-la.
Vite, vite.
J'ai pas fait ça depuis 20 ans.
Où est le crochet ? Et voilà.
Maintenant, c'est bon.
Tirez, Mike.
Il faut qu'on charge celle-ci.
Prêt. 2, 3, tirez !
Ça y est presque !
2, 3, tirez !
Tirez sur cette corde, Mike !
Encore !
C'est bon.
- Allez !
- Donnez-moi ça.
Oui ! Peter,
on a une solution de tir.
- Referme, Mike.
- Ok.
Chargez-le.
C'est bon. Paré à lancer !
Torpille en approche !
Torpille en approche.
C'est parti.
- Tube 2.
- Tube 2 ! Feu !
Torpille lancée.
350 mètres !
La torpille approche.
C'est quoi ce bin's ?
Torpille en approche !
- Gare au choc !
- La nôtre survole...
- Oh merde !
- Fais voir.
Alerte générale...
Explosion à 0-2-0 degrés...
Alerte générale,
tous à vos postes de combat.
- Flammes sur l'eau !
- Grenade anti-sous-marine...
Ce n'est pas
un cargo de ravitaillement !
Non.
Je l'entends exploser.
On a réussi !
Bien joué.
On peut dire que ça fait de nous
et du bateau des héros.
Objet en approche.
Grenade anti-sous-marine !
Cramponnez-vous !
- Putain...
- Tout le monde va bien ?
- Vick ?
- Je vais bien.
On l'a échappé belle.
Garmin...
Pourquoi on s'arrête ?
J'imagine que c'était pas prévu.
Quoi donc ?
Tout s'éteint. Pourquoi ça s'éteint ?
Merde ! En voilà une autre.
Putain !
Va chercher la lampe là-bas.
Tu l'as ?
Merde. Fait chier !
- Attrape ça.
- On est dans la merde.
- 35 mètres.
- Jusqu'où on peut descendre ?
Jusqu'au fond, si on ne fait rien.
40 mètres.
Ce n'est qu'un cauchemar...
Un problème ?
Tout va bien ?
Ça va ?
Vicki !
Vick.
Elle est morte.
Putain de merde.
On a fait le maximum, merde !
Pete, pourquoi ?
Et maintenant ?
Pourquoi on est encore là ?
Oui, Garmin, dites-le-nous.
Hein ?
Pourquoi ?
On est ici à cause
de ta putain d'obsession.
- Mike...
- Regarde-moi.
Voilà où tu nous as menés.
- Belle réussite !
- Mike...
Quoi, Stace ?
Tu veux qu'on meure tous ?
Pour la gloire de son grand-père ?
Qu'on soit tous des héros ?
Tu sais quoi ?
Moi je veux sortir de là
avant qu'on crève tous.
Garmin, vous pouvez m'aider
à la porter ?
S'il vous plaît.
Il faut la relever.
Doucement.
Va te faire foutre, Pete.
Peter, c'est pas...
Il a raison.
C'est ma faute.
C'est ma faute si vous êtes là.
Mon Dieu.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait là ?
On s'éloigne encore.
Il doit y avoir quelque chose ici
pour nous guider.
- Trouvez quoi.
- Allez vous faire foutre !
Vous qui savez, parlez.
Écoutez. Le ministère de la Défense
a besoin que je sois ici.
Alors cessez vos questions.
Peter n'avait jamais pu monter à bord.
Vous saviez ?
Vous saviez ce qui allait arriver,
mais n'avez rien dit.
Je ne pouvais pas.
J'avais des ordres...
On s'en tape !
Il fallait prévenir.
Mon intervention
pouvait modifier le dénouement.
Vous parlez encore de dénouement.
Putain !
Qu'entend-il par "dénouement" ?
J'en sais rien.
Mais je vais le découvrir.
Pas l'endroit idéal
pour garder un secret.
Très bien.
Vous voulez des réponses ?
Je vais vous en donner.
J'ai reçu l'ordre d'observer
et de faire un rapport.
Et de ne pas interférer.
Jusque-là j'avais saisi :
observer, informer, sans interférer.
Votre super plan gouvernemental
prévoit-il d'autres surprises ?
Il fallait que je sois là, Ok ?
Je n'en savais rien.
Eux si. Ils ne m'ont rien dit.
- Ça craint d'être en bout de chaîne.
- Exact, ça craint.
Mais je sais que c'était nécessaire.
Si j'avais su que j'allais rester,
j'aurais peut-être
fait quelque chose, ou pas.
Dans tous les cas,
mieux vaut ne pas
changer le cours de l'histoire.
Désormais,
la situation est trop critique.
- Pourquoi ?
- Réfléchissez.
L'équipage du Lionfish
était censé embarquer demain.
C'est nous,
l'équipage du Lionfish en 1943 ?
Nous savons juste que cet événement
a eu lieu et quelle fut son issue.
Trop tard, vous nous avez aidés.
Vous avez déjà changé
les règles et l'histoire.
Vous vous foutez de moi ?
C'est pour ça qu'on est là ?
Désolée, mais je ne vais pas
laisser le destin
décider de notre sort.
- Je vais en parler à Peter.
- Non...
Impossible.
On doit être sûrs qu'il fera
tout ce qu'il a fait la 1e fois.
Écoutez, c'est très grave.
Peter ne doit être au courant de rien.
On doit partir du principe
que rien n'est arrivé par hasard.
- J'ai pu lui dire.
- On l'ignore. Mais...
le suicide du grand-père de Peter
semble être le catalyseur
qui l'a conduit ici.
Ce serait beaucoup plus facile
si Peter savait.
C'est impossible. Faites-moi
confiance, il ne doit rien savoir.
On n'obtiendra rien de lui,
il est hors de lui.
Raisonnez-le,
il faut terminer tout ça.
Il ne m'a jamais écoutée,
pourquoi le ferait-il ?
Aujourd'hui, ce serait bien.
D'accord.
- Vous avez intérêt à avoir raison.
- J'ai raison.
Bon, voilà.
Je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais nous, on n'a pas l'intention
de crever sur ce pauvre rafiot.
Une chose nous a échappé.
Alors on va se creuser la tête
et trouver la réponse, Ok ?
Garmin, vous êtes libre.
Très bien.
Attends.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Le Lionfish aurait
été attaqué par les siens.
Ah oui ? On s'est déjà occupé de ça.
Leurs grenades
visaient le sous-marin allemand.
Ils nous prennent pour des Allemands.
- Et ils n'arrêteront qu'à notre mort.
- Oui !
Et si on leur disait par radio
qu'on est américains ?
Impossible à cette profondeur.
Attendez.
Il reste un moyen de communiquer.
Comment ?
Un vieux truc de sous-marinier.
Ils tiraient à blanc
depuis les tubes à torpilles
remplis d'huile de cuisine,
de graisse,
de déchets, de vêtements divers,
pour que l'ennemi, en surface,
pense qu'ils étaient morts.
Mais ce n'est pas ce qu'on va faire.
- Ah non ?
- Non.
Nous voulons
qu'ils sachent qu'on est en vie.
Nous voulons qu'ils sachent
qu'on est américains.
Et comment on va faire ?
C'est la dernière.
Le drapeau américain...
Voyons voir. Ça c'est bon.
Ça aussi.
Les tablettes, non.
- Peter.
- Ça, oui.
- Peter ?
- Oui.
Vos tablettes.
Quoi ?
Mettez-les aussi.
Ça va pas,
il y a toutes mes recherches.
Tu devrais l'écouter.
C'est bon, tu peux fermer.
- Pas le choix.
- Vous rigolez ?
À quoi bon ? La tablette
n'existait pas à l'époque.
Ne t'en mêle pas.
- Je les mettrai pas.
- Faites-le.
Ne me donnez pas d'ordres.
Écoute-le.
Vraiment ?
Vos tablettes dans la caisse, allez.
Sérieux ?
- Que faites-vous ?
- Allez.
Que faites-vous ?
- Mettez vos tablettes dans la caisse.
- Peter...
Quoi ?
Tu devrais lui faire confiance.
À un type qui me braque
avec une arme ?
Montrez-lui la lettre.
De quoi vous parlez ?
Expliquez-moi ce qui se passe.
Montrez-lui.
La lettre de ton grand-père.
"Cher M. Williams,
"Notre situation, celle du pays,
"devient critique
et je dois me montrer responsable.
"J'ignore pourquoi vous nous aidez,
"mais ces dernières 24h
me laissent espérer la victoire.
"Douloureuse peut-être,
mais une victoire.
"Vos actes héroïques
à bord de ce bateau
"m'ont prouvé
que l'avenir était tracé,
"et c'est à mon tour d'agir.
"Il en va de mon devoir
envers mon pays.
"Je n'agis pas par égoïsme,
mais par lucidité.
"Mon rang et ma place
sont sur le Lionfish.
"Je ne peux l'abandonner
ni ignorer la détresse
"de tous les hommes qui ont péri
pour leurs frères et leur pays.
"Par cet acte, je remets
entre vos mains le sort mon bateau,
"celui de l'équipage et du pays.
"Respectueuses salutations,
Tony Sterling."
Ok. Donne-moi la caisse.
- Le premier bouton.
- Paré.
Ok. C'est parti, feu !
- Qu'y a-t-il ?
- Pas assez d'air comprimé.
- Putain !
- On ne peut pas en produire plus ?
- Stace, ça va ?
- Il faut retourner au central.
- Tu vas bien ?
- Oui.
- Il y a une lampe là-bas.
- Ça va ?
Allez-y, on vous suit.
Allez.
Sûre que ça va ?
Attention.
Le compresseur demande
plus de puissance.
Avancez !
Fait chier !
- Alors ?
- Même pas assez pour ma lampe !
On est foutus.
Je peux le réparer.
Oui, je peux le réparer.
Les batteries sont en série
pour une puissance maximale.
-Inutile d'alimenter tout le navire.
- Le bateau.
Si je refais le câblage
des batteries en parallèle,
la puissance suffira
à lancer le compresseur. C'est simple.
Et c'est possible ?
Oui, ça l'est.
Vous attendez quoi ? Une médaille ?
Je m'occupe du compresseur.
Allons au compartiment de batterie.
On y voit rien.
Ok. Vas-y.
Stace, tu peux m'éclairer par ici ?
Là, sur la gauche.
Non, de l'autre côté.
Dans la boîte à outils là-bas,
trouve-moi une clé.
- Dépêche !
- Tiens.
Attention !
Tout va bien ?
Dis à Garmin
qu'il y a toujours du jus
et de couper tout le circuit.
- Coupez tout le circuit.
- Ok.
Garmin, coupez tout le circuit.
Essayez pour voir.
C'est bon.
Ok, vas-y.
C'est fait.
Stace !
Stace, Mike !
- Pete.
- Ne bougez pas !
Garmin, au central illico.
Je ne peux plus bouger...
Je la sors de là et je reviens.
Stace...
Garmin !
Oui.
- Ça va aller.
- Je suis là.
Prêt ?
- Oui. Encore.
- Vous avez son bras ?
- Je vais la soulever.
- Je la tiens.
- Vous la tenez ?
- Oui, c'est bon.
- Ça va ?
- Oui...
- Laissez-moi...
- Ok.
- Ça va ?
- Oui.
T'as fait immatriculer ta voiture ?
- Tu vas bien ?
- Oui.
- Je vais voir Mike, Ok ?
- Ok.
- Ça va ?
- Oui.
Mike ?
Mon vieux...
Comment tu vas, mon vieux ?
J'ai connu mieux.
Tu sais...
Ce petit séjour en mer
n'était pas prévu.
- La vie est une aventure.
- C'est clair.
J'ai la solution.
Non...
Ne fais pas ça !
Non !
Mike, non !
Non, arrête.
Oui !
Mikey ?
Et merde !
Qu'est-ce que t'as foutu ?
Putain.
T'as réussi.
Merci.
Merci, mon vieux.
Quoi ?
Mikey...
Il y est resté.
Est-ce que ça va ?
- Il n'a pas survécu.
- Ok.
- Vas-y...
- Je dois y aller.
Ça marche.
Oui ! On rentre à la maison.
Cessez le feu !
- Alerte générale.
- Reçu.
92 degrés.
272 mètres, débris en vue.
Vigie tribord,
recherchez des survivants.
Que vois-tu, Jack ?
Nom de Dieu, Jack !
C'est un drapeau américain.
C'est pas vrai !
0-9-1-2-9-8 degrés.
Cessez le feu !
Bordel de merde,
qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Un sous-marin américain,
regardez le drapeau.
- Sous-marin US à tribord.
- Des survivants ?
J'y crois pas, Jack !
- Autre chose, Jack ?
- Rien du tout.
Il y a quelques gilets
de sauvetage. Merde.
Je ne vois pas
de survivants pour l'instant.
Équipes de sauvetage...
Continuez à chercher.
Quoi ?
Claquer des talons ne nous a
pas ramenés au Kansas, Dorothy.
Je ne comprends pas. Que...
- Je ne sais pas.
- Pardon ?
Je ne sais pas.
Quelque chose aurait dû...
Alors.
Quoi, j'ai raté un truc ?
Il y a eu un problème.
On ne devrait plus être ici
à l'heure qu'il est.
Vous voulez dire que...
vous ne savez pas
ce qui va se passer ?
Donc c'est fini ?
On est...
On est morts ?
Ça va aller.
Monsieur Garmin.
Cette opération
est classée secret défense.
Vous ne devez jamais en parler
à quiconque. Est-ce clair ?
C'est pour cela
que tout était gardé secret
et le bateau sous scellés.
Nous nierons que tout ceci est arrivé.
Nous savions que
vous viendriez depuis 70 ans.
Des millions de vies en dépendaient.
Vous n'avez pas sauvé qu'un cargo.
Vous êtes un homme brillant.
Pensez donc.
Votre tablette a été analysée
en laboratoire.
Non seulement ses composants,
mais aussi toutes vos archives
sur la guerre.
Mais lorsqu'ils ont repêché la caisse
contenant vos outils informatiques,
ils étaient à des années lumières
d'imaginer cela en 1943.
Nous avons pu introduire
d'énormes avancées technologiques.
Grâce aux résultats de vos travaux,
nous avons gagné
la 2e Guerre mondiale.
Mais...
le Lionfish...
Pourquoi...
Le dossier sur votre grand-père
sera rectifié.
Il a donné sa vie pour ce pays
et pour vous.
C'est pour votre grand-père.
Je ne sais pas quoi dire.
Tu avais raison, Peter.
Ton grand-père était exceptionnel.
Vous pouvez récupérer ceci.
Ma tablette.
Gardez-la. Je ne pense plus
en avoir besoin.
Je m'attendais à cette réponse.
Ces histoires de marins
ne meurent jamais, hein ?
Soyez tranquille.
De hautes fonctions vous attendent
dans une unité de recherche
du ministère de la Défense.
Avec un budget plutôt confortable.
Et si je préfère raconter
l'histoire de mon grand-père ?
Accepte leur offre.
En plus,
personne ne vous croirait.